Okay.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Monday morning podcast.
Just before Friday.
Nah,
just checking in on you.
What's going on?
It's the day after thanksgiving.
I know I'm a day late,
but you know,
we had to celebrate dia defeated the British yesterday with a big meal.
You liked that England.
Remember that when we kicked your ass.
And that's third Thursday in November.
All those fucking centuries ago you showed up and you're dumb.
Red Blazers,
right?
Your big stupid hatch.
We hit behind rocks and trees like men,
right?
Picking you off and Crispus addicts walked up.
He said,
I can't tell a lie.
I'm the one who pissed in the gravy.
Right.
And Benedict Arnold at con went up and he fucking slid a meter here.
Yeah,
right.
Then George Washington walked over to Thomas Jefferson.
He said,
hey,
when you're done,
bang in one ear,
slaves,
why don't you help me kick the fucking British Outta here?
Thomas said,
okay.
And he put his fucking pirate hat back on,
right?
And they went out to the Potomac.
George Washington standing up in the boat.
You know,
but ignoring all rules,
rules,
all the rules,
a row in a fucking boats sit down your dose.
You're fucking with the ballots.
We get it.
We're going to do the heavy lifting and you're going to take the credit because
the guy on the bag during the oil paintings going to,
he's going to take more time with you because you're standing up your fucking
ego maniac.
At what business it of yours.
Who fucking Thomas Jefferson fucks.
Huh?
Do you ever think about dead George to matter?
You upset because your wife Martha is,
gets a wooden teeth and that's the story of thanksgiving.
Everybody.
What did it really have to do?
It had to do with a,
we were starving to death and then the native Americans,
one of the biggest blunders taught us how to grow food over here.
They should have just let it die off.
You know
how do it you make Cornif.
Yeah,
I dunno.
Just keep walking and let them freeze to death.
Oh Man.
If they could go back at time,
God damn it.
I don't think there's a native American on a casino in this country that would
say,
you know what,
we fucked up when we showed old pale face out of fucking make some food.
God dammit.
That's right up there.
That's right up there with fucking Hitler.
Not going into Paris right now.
He went into Paris.
That's right.
Rather than driving the allies right out into the fucking oh shit.
You fucked up.
He zigged when he should have zagged.
Anyways.
Did you guys have a nice thanksgiving?
Do you have a good time?
Do know I ate so much yesterday.
I was so fucking full.
I was that level full.
Where's he standing up and sitting down?
Neither one was comfortable,
so I had to keep switching and then leaning against stuff and then it just
really thick,
like understanding bulemia going like,
you know what?
I think it would be great to just,
you know,
walk behind a dumpster right now and let all of this autonomy.
Well,
why was I doing?
Oh my God,
I fucking ate yesterday.
Jesus fucking Christ.
I ate so much yesterday that like I passed out at nine 15 not from booze or
anything like that.
It's just from my fucking body being like,
all right dude,
we got to deal with this.
We need to shut everything else down.
Nine 16.
I remember this the last time I saw and I woke up at like four in the morning,
not even remotely hungry.
I went on a hike with my dog this morning.
We will hike for like about five,
six miles.
I came back.
I still wasn't hungry.
I just ate because that's what you supposed to do in the morning.
And I got halfway through my breakfast and the pain in my stomach come,
came back like,
dude,
we're still,
we're still dealing with what the fuck you did yesterday.
I hope you happy.
I hope you're proud of yourself.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
I uh,
yeah,
I fucking,
I hate me.
And Nia made a obviously Turkey stuffing,
mashed potatoes,
a Mac and cheese,
Collard Greens,
pies,
cranberry sauce.
Fucking,
oh.
And I had a heaping fucking helping them,
all of it.
And I was drinking light beer from Milla all day.
Never had any hard stuff.
Never really got fucked up.
I think I had a glass of wine and then we went over a knee sisters.
That's how we ended it.
And I had that one last piece of Pie and then that was fucking,
that was it.
That was it.
I haven't felt right since.
Um,
but anyways,
to start the day yesterday,
I did do a nice five mile hike.
Banged out a hundred pushups,
45 dips.
Right?
It's,
it's just not even fucking fist.
Not Fuck him.
I mean,
when you eat the way I just ate,
I don't give a fuck if I put on some weight,
but I'm,
I'm,
I am back on it.
All right.
I hike today.
Gaf.
Fuck you.
I was doing so well.
Why did it have to be thanksgiving?
My favorite fucking holiday?
Um,
anyways,
you guys watched the football.
Did you sit around and watch dude,
how fucked up is it actually tweeted about this?
How fucked up is it?
Okay that the programming on Thanksgiving,
they have three NFL football games.
All right.
Thanksgiving,
football,
it,
all,
it all goes together.
The cowboys and the lions have been playing on Thanksgiving since,
I don't know why cowboys,
at least since the 1960s I would think in the lions,
Jesus Christ,
who knows how far back played,
right?
Their goddamn tradition.
Somewhere along the fucking line,
these,
these fucking assholes,
they show the Macy day parade and the Westminster dog show at the same fucking
time as the football's on.
It's almost like they're trying to cause fights.
You know?
Guess what?
My wife likes to watch,
she can't get enough of that Macy day parade.
She absolutely loves it.
And every fucking year I forget,
I got to get home by nine in the morning out here.
Cause that Goddamn parades already can be on.
And the first game starts at noon eastern time,
nine my time,
that'd be fucking year.
Not with the dog.
And I'm thinking,
I'm coming home,
I'm going to make myself a couple of eggs,
all the right.
And then I'm going to sit down,
I'm going to watch the football game.
And every fucking year I'd come home,
you know Kelly and I'll be JAKKS.
We got the fucking Dubbo float.
And of the Goddamn parade is already on.
My wife is in some ridiculously,
I love the holidays mood,
so I can't change the fucking channel.
Right.
So this is the first time in my life where I've actually had more than one TV.
So I went downstairs this year and I'm thinking,
oh great,
I'll fucking record the thick,
but what does she do?
Come upstairs.
What's the joy?
The holiday together.
And I'm like,
well I want to watch the football.
She goes,
you know,
and she just pouts yeah,
fuck it's next thing you know you're upstairs.
Right.
And people are doing that stupid,
you know,
fucking dance.
I can't stand.
I absolutely fucking hate it.
Is that thing with does it co couple,
right.
They always do this on dancing with the stars when they're,
the two of them are coming towards the camera towards the audience like that
doing that chat,
chat,
chat thing.
Right.
They're not quite cheek to cheek,
but they're facing one another and as they're walking towards you,
they keep switching their legs,
twisting them,
you know?
Okay.
Like one,
two,
three,
and this side.
Are they one,
two,
three on the other side and want to,
they sit there with this ridiculous smile on your face,
like you're supposed to be impressed.
It's that fucking NFL thing.
Well,
you'll run through the tires sideways kind of thing or whatever the fuck it is.
It's one of those things except they're dancing.
It never goes with the music.
It's just supposed to be visually exciting I guess.
Even though we've all seen it a thousand fucking times.
If anybody who's listening to my podcasts indulges in the world of dance and can
tell me what that fucking dance move is and then can tell me the,
uh,
the head of the Union of the dance board,
if I could write a fucking letter or send an email requesting that,
that dance be a,
you know,
why don't we just take,
you can't watch a dance competition with somebody doesn't do that and everybody
thinks it's fucking amazing.
That and dipping somebody while they dance.
Everybody,
the crowd always goes up,
I guess the greatest fucking thing ever.
What is that stupid fucking move called?
You know that thing I'm talking about like they,
it's like the exorcist,
you know when they head spins around,
but you're doing it with the bottom part of your body.
Like your torso from your waist up is still facing your partner,
right?
And your legs are underneath the normally and now it's like,
oh wow.
Does she have a double jointed spine that go in the other way?
Okay.
I don't know me.
Please send me a video that and then I'll retweet it and then I'll see what the
fuck it is.
And by the way,
the pie video,
pie crust video is coming.
I was just going to shoot it on my iPhone and my buddy who helps me out the
podcast,
he goes,
do it.
If we're going to do it,
let's do it right.
We'll shoot it right.
So he gets back today.
So I will be making a pie crust video for all you fucking Christmas cards out
there.
Um,
but anyways,
I hope you guys all had a,
a a nice day despite the fact that I fucking overrate I over ate the way.
Like,
you know,
when you drink so much,
you don't have a good time.
You know,
you start getting a bed spins,
you know,
in the bar,
like that type of shit.
Like I ate to that level and um,
I'd like to say,
Oh,
I'm disgusted with myself,
but it tasted so fucking good.
I'm not.
MMM.
So anyway,
seriously,
I hope you guys all had a happy thanksgiving.
I had a wonderful one and this was the best year of my life,
both personally and professionally.
I,
I dunno,
I just keep having more fun.
Every God damn year it's been working out good for me.
You know,
it's kind of weird.
There's,
the planet is slowly dying.
I just seem to be having more fun with each year.
You think,
think what the polar ice caps melting and the food oceans being fished out that
they would affect my mood.
I think,
you know,
it really has helped me to stay positive is I feel like it's inevitable that
we're going to destroy ourselves.
So once you just sort of given to that and you're like,
well,
there's nothing I can fucking do about it,
you know,
next thing you know,
you're a,
you know,
here are you to having a little pony ride,
you getting on the Ferris wheel,
you know,
you're like,
well,
you know,
when we have some fun,
I'm going to have as much fun as I can have before we fucked this whole thing
up.
And even if we don't,
I mean,
every once in a while,
you know,
an asteroid is going to come by every couple of fucking zillion years.
Right.
I don't want to piss anybody off here like Google did with their,
uh,
their Lucy thing,
which I'd never even heard of.
I guess he found these fucking bones in Ethiopia and it was sort of a half a hap
human.
It looked like an eight,
but like somebody you could talk to at the same time,
you know,
the way they flushed it out,
like it didn't look like the fucking like chimpanzees that we all know now eat
other monkeys and rip people's faces off.
If you want to know more about that.
Listen,
I did an episode of the Joe Rogan experience to promote afters for family.
Uh,
Joe Rogan saw the clip of the show and he invited me on the show,
which is,
you know,
twice Joe Rogan.
He's the fucking best.
So anyways,
we talked about that.
Joe told me some fucking horrific story about how this footage of chimpanzees,
you know,
where we start to eat bananas,
but they like eat other monkeys and a,
they don't really kill them.
They just start eating them.
It's fucking as the other monkeys screams and fucking pain.
They just sort of sit there,
you know,
sadistic motherfuckers.
Anyways,
what the fuck am I talking about?
I'm talking about Lucy,
right?
Who?
Like I said,
it looks like an eight,
but you feel like you could talk to it.
And,
um,
so they did this little creationism,
I guess,
is it creation is no,
not create creation.
Those,
those are the God people they did.
The more,
uh,
you know,
we came from the mud and then we were apes thing with their drawing.
Am I explaining this even remotely?
Right?
You know,
when you go on Google,
all right.
And then every day they got something,
like if it's Albert Einstein's birthday,
they'll spell out Google with like a fucking white afro or some shit.
Um,
they did something for,
uh,
you know,
who is Lucy or whatever.
And they made it like there was a monkey on all fours and then an eight kind of
walking on two legs upright and then a man.
And uh,
it said yes,
the Google use one of its signature doodles to come or emirate,
the 41st anniversary of the discovery of Lucy,
the name of a collection of fossils,
you know,
the fucking AP,
you feel like you could talk to blah,
blah,
blah.
Uh,
it was a significant moment for our understanding of evolution.
But many creationists weren't happy about Google promoting the theory of
evolution on their homepage.
So here's some of the tweets.
Uh,
somebody wrote and before any hashtag fossils once lived,
um,
God created the heavens and the earth.
Genesis 1.1,
please remove Lucy from my homepage
for the life of me.
I don't understand why people who are into creationism get upset by the stuff.
Like it doesn't make any sense.
You know,
what do you give a fuck what these guys think?
Um,
another one,
since a la parentheses,
God and creation have much proofs than evolution.
I expect to see something about it on your homepage.
This is the one that I actually liked to pushing your beliefs on.
Others are you Google?
Isn't that what you godless folks?
Object to about Christians?
That's a fucking great.
Give it up for Jim Jensen.
Everybody.
That's a great one because when you be upset,
if they fucking a,
I dunno all these fucking open minded people who,
who want to go with like a,
you know,
the scientific,
proof of,
of how we got here,
which is,
you know,
we're never going to figure it out.
This is the thing,
we're never going to figure this shit out because even these people cause like
the people who are into God,
I do believe in God,
no matter how far back science goes,
it has to be like,
oh yeah,
I see what you're,
a bunch of Amoebas,
uh,
in the ocean.
Then they just go,
well who,
the Amoebas man.
And no matter how far back you go,
you go who they go,
well,
who created that right?
Never addressing the fact that there Adam and eve sin doesn't,
as far as what we've found in the ground,
you know,
and how old the bones are and what they say in the Bible.
When Adam and eve lived in all this bullshit,
it doesn't even add up.
So then all they do is just no matter what science comes up with,
they go,
well,
who came up with that man?
But can't you do that to the God?
People be like,
all right.
So before there was anything,
there was God.
Okay.
And where did he,
where was he?
If there wasn't anything,
And who created that?
And who created him?
He was just here.
It doesn't make it and none of it makes any fucking sense.
And I don't think we're supposed to understand.
We're supposed to continue to move forward,
try to get bigger TVs and destroy one another.
That is our destiny.
All right?
And some people got upset saying that they felt that Google was saying that they
were monkeys.
All right.
Hi.
How are we from monkey?
You believe it.
I don't like how they deliberately take the ones that are misspelled.
First generation should be from Adam,
Adam and eve.
Not Bullshit.
Monkey.
The world is on fire and the moron bubbled dwellers at Google.
Uh,
just help their godless agenda Lib.
Tards um,
I love godless.
That's so fucking so fucking great description.
Um,
all right.
And then,
okay,
here's the people who got an pissed off that a Google was implying that they
were monkeys.
All right?
This person writes,
I'm not a fucking monkey.
Maybe white people came from monkeys,
but colored people been native to this planet.
All right,
so your home page is saying all humans came from monkeys.
You have no proof,
just a made up theory to avoid the truth of creation of funny.
Is that as opposed to you what your book that thought the world was flat?
Uh,
I might be bugging,
but is it just me or did Google mock the black race by making a monkey revolve
revolve into a man that's not cool at all?
For,
first of all,
it's evolve and also the man in the photo was white.
I think.
I have no fucking idea.
I just,
I dunno.
I just find an interest in the people get that fucking pissed off.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
why do you give it?
Why do you give a fuck what other people think?
It's not like,
oh,
I guess maybe because it's a control thing.
I Dunno.
I don't,
I don't see it.
I don't see it at all.
Uh,
I don't give a shit.
Right?
Is that dumb?
Is that,
is that uh,
my hypocrite?
Am I gonna be in the river Haiti's or whatever the fuck they talk about?
It's another black Friday.
Everybody now that black Friday,
what people who have absolutely no respect for themselves and their own fucking
well big go down to a fucking store to find three BB guns that have been marked
down 80% while everything else is the exact same fucking price.
People,
I say this every year,
get better than this cave.
A little bit of fucking respect for yourself.
All right?
Why don't you stay home today?
Stay home,
chill out,
know,
enjoy the rest of you have Thanksgiving weekend,
you know,
and then next,
next week.
How about Monday night after work?
Why don't you just waltz into the store,
step over the dried blood on the floor from last Friday.
Just step over that.
Walk in there and just buy something that you can afford.
You know,
there's no shame in it.
There's no shame in being fucking like having money problems.
You don't have to get hurt over it.
Just fucking buy something that you can afford and that's it.
Yeah,
it's just shit.
It's stuff like that fucking TV that they say and he used to be a thousand,
now it's only 40 bucks.
You're going to go in there and do like fucking,
you know,
five grand with the damage to your limbs trying to get to the thing.
And I,
for one,
it's a flatscreen TVs have people shit,
fucking two years,
two years is probably not even worth for a while.
Maybe it's worth 40 bucks.
I don't know.
Here's my thing.
The second is a fucking line and pushing and shoving.
I've always just said,
you know what?
Fuck that.
Occasionally I fucked up.
Occasionally I've gone down to like,
uh,
you know,
I dunno.
Pink's hot dogs fucking labrea and stood in that line for 90 minutes to get a
fucking hot dog that just tasted like a hot dog.
And I was like,
yeah,
there you go.
Bill.
What'd you learn?
I'm trying to think what would be worth,
I don't know.
The planet is going to explode
in fucking two hours and then there's a 90 minute line.
I would stand in that,
but then I'm also thinking like,
all right,
so then we're going to be up there.
And what outer space?
Wow.
Booboo.
Right?
It's like 90% fucking men.
You know what black chick up there.
Was there any other fucking women
on Star Trek?
Is that like Kirk always late and am I doing hacky material from the 86 is that
what cook landed and fucking was so horny?
Every place he went fucking them green bitches.
I'm sorry.
Anyway,
so why don't I,
why don't I read the one advertiser I seem to have left on this podcast.
They really don't have a sense of humor.
Do they?
All right.
Um,
okay.
What's the name of this fog?
Ziprecruiter's everybody zip recruiter.
As a business,
your company is only
as good as the people you hire posting jobs in one place.
Well that's not enough to find quality candidates.
Short staffing leaves little time to post to dozens of job sites.
So what do you do?
Jesus Christ.
Wouldn't it be great if there was a website you could go to post your position
and have it go out to a Zillion Goddamn people?
Well,
relax.
Zip recruiters can post to 100 plus job sites with one single click.
Be instantly matched to candidates from over 6 million resumes.
Plus Watch brand new candidates roll into ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use interface within 24 hours.
Zip recruiter has been used by over 400,000 businesses.
Uh,
insert approved user testimony.
Please.
Reference testimonial addendum document.
Well,
I didn't do any of that.
Did I?
Uh,
today you can try it.
Look,
what the fuck do I got to do that for?
They know what this is.
If I,
if I needed to hire some of my business,
I would use it.
This totally makes sense.
Okay.
You got the goods.
They're going to buy it today.
You can try ZipRecruiter for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burr.
That's ziprecruiter.com/burr.
One more hack,
ziprecruiter.com/burp.
Um,
oh,
I got to hear MVMT watches.
Michael Victor,
Michael Thomas.
All right.
Sample intro,
make your own.
Now I'm reading yours.
Thanks to movement watches for their sponsorship of this podcast.
They sent over some watches and boy,
oh boy,
I haven't got them yet.
I haven't got him yet.
I'm sure they're nice.
Who doesn't like a watch check?
'Em Out is what it was with.
It was this little crowdfunded brand that is revolutionizing the watch game.
Uh,
they are starting to get a lot of press from Gq.
Playboy hypebeast askmen said they are the hottest watch company on the market.
They're all about the idea that high quality doesn't have to break the bank and
they actually deliver probably why they have over 1 million social media
followers.
Fucking bastards.
They got 10 times when I got quality crafted watches starting at just $95 if you
tried to get a watch like this at the department store,
you'd be spending at least 400 to $500.
This style is minimalistic,
clean,
and sleek.
In other words,
it's got clayish.
You can weigh this thing at the office during the day or out at the bars at
night.
It's new,
it's shap.
And it's an all day where please spell MVMT when you're saying the URL and the
call to action.
All right,
here comes the call to action.
Everybody.
I'm going to help you get your style on point.
Checkout and VMT.
That's Michael Victor,
Michael Tango,
watches.com/ [inaudible] we're hooking you up with 50% off your entire purchase.
That's m t
Michael Victor,
Michael Tango,
watches.com/burr MVMT watches.com/bar check 'em out.
You know what?
That makes a great kip break Christmas gift,
doesn't it?
You know,
you put that under the tree and you know what?
You stick in this stocking stuffer.
You know what?
You get your loved one.
A couple of tickets to the fourth annual Patrice O'Neal comedy benefit.
January 26th,
that's a Tuesday at seven o'clock at the city center in New York City.
Um,
this has become an annual event.
It's one of my favorite things to do.
It's attribute of one of my great friends I ever had in life and the funniest
goddamn comedian I ever saw live Patrice O'Neil.
I'm still can't believe it.
It's been a
Jesus.
What did he died November 29th,
2011.
What was it,
the 28th sometime right around here was four years ago.
So,
um,
we do the benefit to keep his name out there and we also do the benefit to a
financial,
we help out the people that he was taken care of when he was living.
And um,
it's the greatest thing ever because I'm so proud of that benefit because I feel
like all of his friends stepped up and um,
okay.
I think if he was around and see what we were doing for them,
I think it would be the one time he would actually not trash us at least for
like 30 seconds before he did.
Um,
so it makes a great stocking stuffer and it's in,
it's a,
you're helping out,
uh,
the friends and family of the greatest comic that I ever saw.
All right.
This January 26th,
that's a Tuesday at the city center.
I will be posting the link.
We are already halfway sold out.
These tickets always go quickly.
Um,
couple of clicks and you could take care of somebody for Christmas and that's
one less thing you got to worry about and you don't have to get tackled in a
fucking department store.
Look at these God damn people,
Jesus Christ,
just grabbing at some big fucking TV bursting through.
I don't know legally how they're allowed to do this.
Like every year somebody gets fucking hurt.
It's like,
how is this not inciting a riot?
Black Friday on sale from a to Friday,
November 28th,
some sort of fucking TV.
Everybody with their big winter coats.
Look at this guy fucking three adults just completely losing their fucking
composure.
Then I love the TV cameras.
This sitting there laughing,
watching all these fucking people,
it seems a little less violence.
You guys see the video clip of the woman just she's clinging to a flat screen.
TV is somebody else drags it down the aisle.
She's got like,
what
the fuck are you doing?
What are you doing?
Oh,
they hoard it up here at cheerleaders.
Keep crowds going at the Wembley store in north.
Oh my God,
this is England.
I love it.
They bought into it too.
Oh,
that's tremendous.
That's fucking tremendous.
Just when you think we can't get any dumber,
all fucking London comes into fucking save rs little tykes playhouse.
Bullies do.
You went there and got some first kid.
I don't know.
I don't fucking get it anyways.
It's not worth it.
Do you know the other day I was looking,
I was looking at cars,
right?
My wife needs a new car and a,
okay.
I went in and I looked at the car and as I was getting out of the car,
another buyer comes along.
He goes,
what'd you think of it?
It's a queen mean.
What the fuck did I think of it?
None of your fucking business.
What?
I thought of it.
The salesman's right here.
If I think of something about it,
I've got to negotiate.
I'm not gonna tell you that.
I like it.
And then he gets in the car to go fucking test drive it.
So the,
so then the,
the,
the fucking salesman is go,
oh,
you know,
so what are we doing here?
It's like,
I dunno,
what are we doing here?
I just took that thing for ride that cut just drove away in it.
So now what?
Now what?
I'm going to fucking bid on the car against this fucking guy.
Sell it to him.
So if I thread my said dad,
go fuck yourself.
And that was the end of the day.
I don't do that shit.
Start competing with this guy.
I,
I honestly,
I just don't give a shit.
I don't give a fuck.
Right?
Am I nuts?
Like that?
My crazy is that,
is that insensitive?
At some point I'll figure it out.
I never know how to do that shit.
Anyways.
Um,
so anyways,
let's plow ahead here.
I'm sitting here battling.
All right.
The fucking patriots beat the Goddamn buffalo bill swept our asses for the year,
which I love,
cause I wish any fucking ill will on them.
They're fucking fans would talk so much.
God Damn Shit to me.
All right,
fucking rex.
Ryan's always talking shit.
It's always nice that they got the old right there,
Fred fucking twice this year so they can shut their fucking wing.
Eaton faces for another God damn year.
All right.
Having said that,
I still think rex is a great coach.
He just needs a quarterback and they got a hell of a defense.
They got a hell of a difference.
But it was fun watching them all,
all the bills,
fans tweeting at me,
giving me all this fucking shit in the first half and then they just slowly go
away.
This is,
I got overreading hiccups in the morning.
How pathetic is this?
This is like Le Leftover from yesterday.
Um,
and my fucking Boston Bruins,
they're a,
they got a nice all three game winning streak they got arranges today,
which is obviously will be a tough game,
but I'm psyched that uh,
you know,
hopefully this starting to turn it around here.
I Dunno.
We'll see what they do with the trade deadline.
Maybe they'll get,
they'll pick up somebody.
Um,
well who knows.
Maybe a draft pick will turn into something.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
So a,
I think I'm going to go to the auto show today.
I'm going to go down there and see what the fuck's going on.
Cause I don't like,
don't like fucking,
I don't like salesman car salesman.
You barely get on the lot.
The same thing.
Like when you walk into a fucking store second you walk into soil,
hey,
how are you?
What can I do your for?
You know,
I like those ones.
You walk in and they go,
hey,
how are you?
Let me know if you need anything.
Then I'm like,
all right,
I can relax now and I'm probably going to buy something.
And it's like you're all looking forward and particular yeah,
I'm looking for you to fuck off.
Well I,
I,
I'm,
I'm an adult.
If I see something that I like,
I will take it off and I will try it on and I will make my decision.
I don't need you to fucking sort of a grease the pipes here.
All right,
so why don't you and your little fucking a
okay.
Michael J.
Fox outfit.
Yeah.
Alex p Keaton.
I mean outfit.
Why don't you go ahead you guys,
when she was fuck off,
why don't I ever have the nerve to say that,
you know,
I just don't have to fucking polite.
Can I help you?
Yeah.
You know,
you get to help me.
You could just leave me alone until I find what I want.
Like how do you say that nicely?
Yeah.
Some woman said something to me the other day in a fucking store and I wanted to
say something back to her,
but I was just like,
they would just be too fucking rude and I didn't say it.
Why don't,
why don't I say it?
Wait,
I got say I'm smart enough to fail.
I'm not like everybody says,
I just gotta be a way for me to figure out how to say that nicely.
Can I help you?
Yeah,
you can help me.
Uh,
okay.
Could you,
uh,
I like being left alone and then I'll find what I want and then I go up and buy
it.
Is that cool?
Okay.
You fucking God.
Oh,
let's work on some scenarios.
Excuse me,
sir.
Can I help you with,
that's,
that's too aggressive.
Dial it back.
Can I help you?
No,
no he can't.
I don't need any help.
If I need help,
I'll ask you sir.
Please.
Was that polite?
Oh,
gives a shit.
Right.
Can I help you now?
Now you can't help me.
Okay.
Yeah,
he can help me.
Can you fucking take a,
a price tag off as something a lot cheaper and put on the thing I want.
Can you do that?
Well,
yeah.
You can't help it.
Oh,
I'll yell if I want to.
It's my fog can time and I'll yell if I want to.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
That's the fucking post thanksgiving.
A Thursday afternoon podcast.
I know.
I was a bit all over the place.
Um,
oh,
I didn't even talk about any of the fucking games I watched yesterday.
Okay.
Who was the first game?
The lions beat the shit out of the fucking eagles.
Good.
Good Lord.
I'm not really to talk about there.
It was just a one sided affair.
You know what's funny?
Versie picked Sanchez.
He always believed that Sanchez,
like he bought into that Sanchez Shit and I bought into a,
what's his face?
The other guy there when he played on Saint Lewis,
the guy from Oklahoma,
and I can't remember his fucking name.
He looks like Kiana reads.
If he was smart.
What is his fucking name?
Uh,
uh,
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
The Fox,
the guy's name.
I Dunno
who the fuck knows.
And they both ended up on the same goddamn team.
MMM.
I gotta tell you though,
Sanchez isn't as bad as everybody says
he hasn't,
but he also,
he's not a franchise player.
Oh,
really?
Bill,
did you,
did you figure that out?
What?
10 years into his fucking career.
Alright,
plowing ahead then the next game.
Okay.
Was what that was the cowboys versus the path is how great does the Panthers
Defense Look?
Jesus Christ and I felt bad for Tony Romo.
Good Lord.
Thrown right back into the fucking fights.
I still liked that guy.
I know a lot of people don't,
but I gotta tell you,
man,
throwing to pick six.
It's in the same fucking quarter.
I can't remember the last time I saw that.
I think you've got to go back to like Neil O'Donnell.
Uh,
then he gets slammed.
They fucking breaks his God damn collar bone again.
What a brutal fucking season for the cowboys.
I was rooting really hard for those guys.
Uh,
I was kind of hoping that I was going to see Romo come back and he'd win the
remaining like five games of the year or whatever or all the rest of the old
they,
they were two and seven,
right?
Yeah.
So when the remaining seven games of the year,
they go nine,
nine and seven make the fucking playoffs.
I'll tell you what fucking kills me because you guys know I never want to see
Eli again in the playoffs.
A lie fades back to pass.
Okay.
Loses both of his shows it as hell.
Hey,
fumbles the ball.
It goes to the aids out of the other recalls,
you recovered,
it squirts out.
Let's back at Eli's any frozen.
I never said I don't ever want to play that guy again.
Ever play him again.
What's killing me is the giants' record.
They should be in the last or second to last place.
They were in like first place at like five and five aren't they?
Like I think seven and nine could win that division in the history of football.
Get has as a losing record ever won a division.
That's my question for you guys.
I remember years ago,
uh,
the San Diego chargers,
like two years in a row,
they were eight and eight and nine and seven and they won the AFC west and then
went into Indianapolis and beat the colts at home,
by the way.
All right,
for you creationists who still believe in fucking Peyton manning over Tom Brady.
Huh?
I'm fucking with you.
Yeah,
they're five and five.
And they're,
they're like in first place or tied for first place because everybody in that
division is having such a shit fucking year.
And the thing about the giants is they have enough weapons.
They got the coach and they got the quarterback that even though they'll be
fucking seven and nine or eight,
eight and when that division,
you know,
everybody's zero and zero and they get to the playoffs.
And I just,
I just got this weird fucking feeling,
but I gotta tell you this.
So if they have to go down to a no,
I even think they could do that.
I think they could go into Carolina.
I think they could beat the panthers because a,
they know how to fucking win and the panthers are still really young.
You know,
you can tell they're young.
Every time they make a play there talking shit that jumping around,
they're ripping that fucking jerseys open like this superman.
That's,
that's all young people.
Shit.
Yeah.
You know.
Oh,
this is what we do.
City.
Just walking back to the fucking huddle.
Um,
oh God.
I'm such an old concept.
Anyways,
I hope you guys have a wonderful rest of your weekend.
I'm really excited about tomorrow.
That's obviously the big rivalry days in a fury he ever wanted to get into
college football.
The Saturday after thanksgiving.
You got to do it.
You got USC,
Ucla.
You got the a fucking Alabama Auburn.
You get Michigan,
Ohio state.
Why don't you start Michigan,
Ohio state do Auburn,
Alabama and Ucla.
USC.
Even though I don't know how good a good a game that's going to be this year.
But um,
oh man,
it fucking Jim Harbaugh leads fucking Michigan in at fucking beats the buckeyes.
Holy Shit.
Your baby whale,
man.
Dude,
people will fucking,
they will lose it.
God,
their minds,
they will lose their fucking minds.
What a fucking job he did.
Like how much of a cunt could to that guy have been that the 40 niners got rid
of him.
Okay.
I just don't,
I don't get it.
That guy is fucking is unbelievable.
Okay.
He restored the 40 niners they went to a fucking,
they went to a fucking super bowl.
They didn't win it,
but she's,
I just don't fucking understand it.
I just,
for the life of me,
I don't understand why they got rid of that guy.
Um,
I also understand that he is out of his fucking mind,
but he went,
so who gives a shit?
Right?
My nuts.
I don't know.
That's it.
All right.
Whatever.
I'm all over the,
I'm still full of food and Shit and all that type of stuff.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast.
I hope you guys enjoy the rest of the weekend and now please enjoy,
uh,
the,
the throwback,
the last half hour where we take some greatest hits,
some clips from a yesteryear and a Monday,
a long time ago.
All right.
Back when Apes Walk the Earth Upright and you felt like you could talk to them,
but you couldn't.
You know what I mean?
Lucy,
Lucy over here.
What's going on?
God Damn it.
You stink.
All right,
I'll see you
sexting.
Sexting.
All right.
This isn't really,
well this is about this guy.
He,
I remember I told you that story,
um,
about that dude.
Uh,
he worked for some corporations,
see a cubicles.
All right?
And then I'm sure he's on some sort of team.
Everybody has to do some sort of song before they go in there.
Like those poor kids in the building exercises.
Yeah.
Like just people who work at the cold stone creamery.
You ever see them like with like making like the Goddamn,
uh,
ice cream going,
hi Ho.
Hi Ho.
It's off to work.
I like the part of me dies when I see that when I just see people like,
uh,
it's like basically watching someone work in like an ice cream death camp when
I'm in there,
none of them are happy.
None of them dreamed of doing that ice cream.
Death can.
Maybe if you're like a fatty,
you don't know when you got a job in an ice cream store,
kind of like a pedophile getting a job at like a a cub scout camp.
Wow.
Isn't that where they always end up?
I love working with kids.
You know,
I said that last week.
Follow your dreams unless you're a pedophile.
Right?
So answer then using that,
I shouldn't say that.
I have a problem with a fatties working in the ice cream store.
Let,
let's,
let's get to this shit.
So anyways,
so they're going to get everybody in shape.
So they hire some sort of personal trainer and he's trained in everybody.
All right.
And what he does is he gets everybody's emails.
Great move on.
This guy's part fucking great move.
Now he doesn't have to deal with them face to face.
And if there's any fucking hotties he wants to bang,
he can take it to the next level.
Perfect.
That's how you do it.
It's like shooting fish in a fucking barrel or efficient barrel than of in a
shooting gallery.
Um,
so anyways,
so that all of a sudden this guy notices that,
you know,
he gets one text going,
Hey Brad,
you know,
just do a couple more rod jumping jacks and you should be fine.
But for some reason his little hottie wife has to get like 40 fucking texts from
this guy at like 1130 at night.
Oh,
I do remember this.
Yeah.
He and his wife work at the same place.
That's interesting.
At the same place.
Right.
So he fucking a,
he finds out about,
he keeps asking his wife,
I remember this.
Okay.
All right,
well I'm going to recap for people to listen last week.
Right.
So he keeps asking is what keeps catching wife late at night texting going and
he goes,
who are you texting?
And she would immediately slammed the phone shut cause he's got a flip phone
evidently and would say,
uh,
no button either would say nobody or get mad and say nobody.
Right?
So this is not a moron.
He figured out something's up.
He's in the,
he's into some sort of fucking spygate shit where he's at.
He hacks into her thing,
gets her password and sees that all these text messages back and forth to
trainers.
So what is he doing?
He's a God damn man.
Does he slap his fucking wife around?
No.
He goes right to the trainer and says,
Hey,
it says hey sport.
No cause you get sued.
You get sued for that.
Now you get sued for kicking somebody's ass when you're right,
you go.
He goes,
hey sport,
once you do me a favor and stop texting my fucking wife and all hours of the
night.
So then a sport,
oh they're immediately starts acting like a bitch around them.
Starts acting overly nice.
Like you know what all guilty people do.
He's innocent.
He would've gotten mad.
Sure be like,
dude,
what the fuck are you talking about?
I always text people about how to get,
make their core stronger at two in the morning,
I'm dedicated.
Maybe should be inspired by what I'm doing.
I specifically,
I am interested in women having a strong core because they're so beaten down in
society.
You know,
he would have come back with some shit like that,
but he didn't.
Now he's all like,
hey man,
who are you with?
This whole police don't beat the shit out of me and exposed me for being the
dirt bag.
I am.
So I lose this giant moneymaking client here.
Right?
So anyways,
she denies the whole fucking thing.
So he sent a couple of,
uh,
actually a couple of texts that this girl wrote.
Uh,
they were talking about the Beatles and uh,
he writes all those Damn Beatles songs,
make my stomach hurt when I listened to them because it reminds me of getting
ready to go see you.
They give me anxiety.
This is what the trainer is writing to this guy's wife,
not what sort of a exercise are they talking about?
There?
Is that,
uh,
what does that,
is that pushups?
So then she writes back all the lonely people,
where do they all belong?
Oh God.
Right.
And then he said,
I remember you asking me if I related to that song,
if I relate to that song to you,
because I thought you were lonely.
It's talking about our fucking marriage.
Oh,
this guy,
this guy is a dirt bag.
It's like,
I love it.
It's the classic,
he listens to me.
Yeah.
Oh,
this guy,
he's just saying everything.
We talk about music.
Yeah.
My feelings.
Oh yeah.
My husband doesn't do that.
And what it is,
is his dick is,
is,
is downloading all the knowledge in this guy's brain that he has about human
beings.
And he's just given her in the Dick is just,
is,
is basically sitting in the captain Kirk Chair.
He's just fucking anything she wants to hear.
So anyways,
um,
then he write another one.
He said,
I know,
fuck my life.
I wear my fuck my life to sleep and I have a confession to make.
I also wear your panties.
She goes,
lol,
shut up.
He writes.
It's true.
Yeah.
So I dunno what kind of fucking shit this guy's into,
but the real question is not whether or not that that's socially acceptable.
The real question is how did he get this married woman's panties?
He at least finger blasted off.
Would you go with me on that?
I mean,
if mean maybe he's just saying that to be just like controversial.
That's what I thought.
But she goes,
lol,
shut up.
He goes,
it's true.
Okay.
Yeah,
but he does still,
maybe Joe,
you talk into the mic.
Oh,
he made it.
Still be joking around.
But if you're just wearing,
but if he is,
she gave it to him.
How else would he have him?
And they're talking about the Beatles and shit.
She gave it to him if it's true.
Okay.
So that's based what I'm saying.
It's so fucking,
he's got a fucking panties.
They're both adults.
I'm guessing by this.
She's like in her thirties.
What is he doing fingering her and taken her out for a malt.
He's banging her.
He fucking Bangor.
This fucking piece of shit.
Who'd be a great movie.
She a great character for a fucking movie.
Um,
so anyways,
he,
and this is what he said,
his wife,
she's still Dennis denying this whole conversation ever happened.
She's just incomplete,
obviously denial.
She's in denial.
He said,
I'm dumping her,
uh,
not for the reminiscing talk,
but fun,
but for lying to me.
Uh,
he's not interested in trying to,
uh,
please say that Nia and I swear to
got it.
And the throwing my computer,
I will throw this fucking computer at you.
Are you fucking,
he's not interested in what?
I don't know.
Working it out.
Don't throw it.
No,
no,
no.
Go ahead.
I'm just going to leave you with dead silence.
Gonna tell me.
Oh No,
no,
no.
I just,
I don't know.
No,
he's well within his right eye was just posing a question that's all well within
his right.
I don't understand why she doesn't just fess up then.
That's a whole nother topic.
The topic.
I mean what would I know?
Like some things I walking away is missing now.
I feel like part of the story is missing or something.
What the video of them fucking is that what's missing?
What else is missing?
Yeah.
If he's like,
hey mia,
if you start blaming him for not paying attention and that's why she's fucking
this guy,
I will,
I will fucking throw you out of this room.
Morrow,
I'm not to calm down.
That's not what I'm doing.
I'm just saying.
So he says to her,
are you cheating on or you'd fucking this guy?
And she's like,
no,
shut up.
What are you talking about?
Like,
and she just flat out deny.
I don't understand how she can flat out deny something as hard as shit.
That's why I'm so,
she's a lying piece of shit on Nia.
Yeah.
But if you have something and you're like looking at it like this is what you
wrote,
how are you denying it?
Okay.
Cause she just,
she's,
that's what denial is.
You're totally in denial.
I don't have a drinking problem cause you fucking drinking nyquil.
I think it tastes good.
I don't have a problem.
Right?
Yeah.
I like sweeping,
you know?
Uh,
yeah.
You know what it is.
I'm just making sure you keep speaking into the mic.
This is what you kicked her out of it.
I want people to hear what you have to say.
Ah,
okay.
All right.
I ride what?
This is good shit and I'm ruining it.
Fucking Lord.
You know what kills me as she was still like,
it's just,
I dunno.
I'm going to on a piss you off right now.
You ladies will defend you guys defend each other like right there.
And if they,
if a guy did that,
I am not defending her.
Let me,
can I get out my one?
I'm going to say,
if a guy did that shit,
you'd be like,
dump his ass girl.
He's a fucking loser.
You can do better than that.
Call me will lead a little moon pie.
I'll build you up.
That's what the fuck you would have done.
But because yeah,
I just feel like some part of the story is mythic.
What is missing?
I guess nothing.
Thank you Nia.
Thank you for being on the podcast.
Is that what you want?
And you just want me to come with a good fucking 20 minutes?
Yeah.
Not agree with me.
Agree with the decision this guy made.
This isn't about mania.
Please.
Okay.
I'm just a messenger here.
You know,
I'm just trying to do,
I'm just trying to do what's right.
All right.
Because it's very clear what's happening and then you've got someone who's this
lag.
I don't know what you're talking about.
All right,
here's the deal,
man or woman.
Um,
if the person you're with is texting past,
I would even for regular people who aren't in show business,
the Buddhi hour starts after 11.
I would say after 11.
Yeah,
but that's,
but that's what somebody,
you're already fucking okay.
I know you don't understand it because you don't have to talk yourself into it
guys.
We have to,
we have to spin the plates second.
We meet her all the way through.
So you got to be setting it up.
Okay.
I'm always,
you know,
seven 30 is too creepy and stalkerish.
Um,
and I would say a,
you start going past nine 30,
she's going to feel like,
like you just see some sort of tramp if you haven't fucked her yet.
Right.
So you got to you that does that,
does that window,
Huh?
About eight 15 to about 970 you have to do the setup text.
Okay.
And the setup text is not talking about pussy.
It's go,
Oh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm watching Blahblahblah on TV a so and so is so ridiculous.
I'm sort of fucking just to get it going.
You know what I mean?
Right.
Does that seem like Ryan Benign?
Yeah,
like a boxer.
You feel him out in the first round or the Beatles?
Yeah.
You don't load it up,
right?
You're feeling it up.
Yeah.
That's what they're doing.
Right.
This fucking guy this fucking day,
this guy,
you know something as much as a piece of shit is that,
that guy is,
if he writes a book,
I would read it in a second.
And why?
Because you know,
he's got great,
I mean the position he has that's like when I used to take,
I used to take that,
uh,
that yoga class when I was out here and there was that guy out in Santa Monica
and he was a phenomenal fucking teacher and this place was jam packed and it was
by donation only.
So then for tax purposes,
I think he falls under a church.
I know it helped them with taxes and it's all in cash,
so it's all good.
All right.
And then to hottest fucking women.
Some of the hottest women ever move out to La to become actresses.
Okay.
He's got them in his class,
getting up,
getting them all stretched out before he bags him.
It was one of the greatest.
It was,
it was fucking airtight.
Yeah.
And he would go around the class and somehow me having never touched my toes
since I was in the womb with somehow always doing every position correctly.
Yet all these other hotties always needed to be adjusted right around this.
So as,
um,
so I don't get mad at a guy who's got a good thing,
but you,
you know,
stay away from the fucking married ladies.
Yes.
Okay.
Oh,
I know what I wanted to talk about.
How about a moment of silence for another two,
for the next two great men who have,
who are about ready to be sliced in half by their fucking ex wives.
How about a moment of silent for Koby Bryant,
that fucking warrior.
Okay.
Who had an injury to his fucking right hand that would have kept most people out
for half a season.
He didn't even miss a fucking game.
Showed up hitting all kinds of big shots at absolute fucking warrior.
He is about ready to have to fork over $190 million to his fucking ex wife.
And I'm a to,
other than that,
I want to talk to all the fuck of women right now who are going,
that's right.
That's right.
You know,
this is what I want from you guys this week.
All right.
I want you to justify the fucking divorce laws in this country.
I want you to justify them.
I want you to tell me why she deserves $190 million.
I want you to justify it.
Don't just go,
wow,
that that's because that's the law.
Oh,
there you go.
I don't want that.
I want you to justify it.
Like if I asked you why is murder illegal,
you wouldn't be like,
wow,
that's the law that's about it says that you do.
You'd be like,
because life is the most precious thing on this planet and everything has the
right to be alive and you.
You need to respect that you only get one life and for someone to take your life
is the worst thing you could eat.
That's how you would defend that law.
I have fucking racked my brain,
okay?
To try and justify how anybody
is entitled to $190 million of somebody else's fucking money.
Remember that story I told you last week?
Sure.
We all do.
I'm going to bring it up.
This fucking guy got accused of rape,
gets convicted,
goes to jail.
25 years in fucking prison.
They find out afterwards through dead the new DNA technology that he didn't
fucking do it without a doubt.
We had the wrong guy.
You know what he got for 25 years of trying to make sure somebody didn't stick
there dangling in his fucking door knob that he makes sense,
whatever.
He got $4 million,
4 million bucks.
This bitch has been living high on the fucking hog for 10 fucking years,
okay?
You know,
can't even hit a fucking lay up on a God damn nerf hoop set and she's going to
get 190 million fucking dollars.
Ladies,
I want you to justify QP fucking justify that to me.
That is the biggest crock of fucking shit ever.
You know what I,
you know what I love and then I'll got,
well he fucked around.
He fucked around.
Yeah,
he did fuck around.
So he should have to pay for it,
but should be $190 million.
C'Mon.
That's fucking ridiculous.
Some guy gets falsely accused for rape,
spends 25 years in Rikers island.
People slash in each other's faces,
thrown in,
boiling water on each other,
people getting raped.
All this fucking shit.
You got to go through
and you only get $4 million.
His pitch is going to get $190 million.
I love how it's looked down upon to to cheat on your wife,
but it's totally fine to tell somebody that you love them when you're really
don't just because of all the shiny shit that they have.
You know,
look at this.
Look at this woman.
He fucked around on it.
She busted him for five fucking years ago.
The relationships over the trust is gone.
That relationship was fucking over.
Why did she stay?
Cause he bought her that big yellow fucking diamond.
Really?
Okay.
That's why she stays and then what does she do?
She wanted outright,
then she wanted out right then,
but that money was too fucking good.
And that bitch stuck around that big yellow diamonds showing it off very fucking
where she could.
Right.
And then what does she do?
She hangs around like some jaded cop trying to get her fucking pension.
She sticks around for 10 fucking years.
The second 10 years comes around.
She gives us a for Christmas gift.
Hey Colby,
go fuck yourself by the way.
That'll cost you $190 million.
All right.
In my world,
this is how that would work if that,
if she wanted the entire 190 million.
I'm really burning a lot of material here cause I'm going to fucking vent about
this on stage.
So you're hearing this first.
This is like when you hear one of those Zeppelin songs before they fucking a
Polish it off.
All right,
this is too good.
Not to fucking say on stage.
I have to do this shit if I do say so myself or maybe I just love ranting about
their shit.
This is,
this is how she should get this fucking money.
All right.
Hey.
Hey,
whatever your name is,
Bryant,
you know,
isn't it amazing how you never know what their fucking names or you know,
cause cause they don't win any fucking championships doing anything,
right?
Um,
this is how I think that she should get the hundred 90 million.
All right?
You start off,
no matter what misses,
whatever your name is,
Bryant,
you're getting $30 million,
okay?
Which has plenty of fucking money.
You raise a whole God damn family on that.
Live in a nice fucking house and have a nice car and still have 20 million
leftover.
All right?
So no matter what,
you're getting 30 million,
you want to get up to 190 million and let's go down to the staples center,
sweetheart.
All right,
we're gonna start off easy.
You give him a basketball,
you fucking have the whole place jam packed with people screaming at her,
shaking the signs and blowing air horns,
right?
All right.
If you hit a layup,
Mrs,
whatever your name is,
Bryant,
we're going to give you another 5 million,
right?
She hits that you moved to the next round.
Then you go to the foul line.
You want to take another 20 million,
you got to hit a foul shot and everybody's screaming.
Just have a bunch of fucking divorce guy sleeping on futons standing by the back
port screaming at this bitch.
You hit that,
you move to the half court line,
you hit it.
You can only get one shot to just like Coby at the end of the fucking game.
How he made all this money by hitting the big shots when there was fucking
20,000 people screaming at him who didn't want him to do it.
You go to the fucking half court line.
You hit that.
What are we up to?
That's 50 million,
55 million.
We'll give you 50 million,
50 million.
If he hit a half court,
then you go to the full court.
You go full court.
If you hit that,
you get,
you can even do off the back board.
We don't give a shit.
You'll get the other 90 that's how you get your hundred 90 why don't you fucking
earn it?
It's unreal.
Mel Gibson's wife,
no gifts his wife.
You know,
has she even shot a home movie she stands to get,
he's worth at one point was worth 800 million.
She's going to get $400 million.
All right?
I want somebody,
some female,
some human being out there with a vagina to send me an email.
I want you to justify,
justify $400 million.
Tell me why.
I don't think you could do it other than say,
wow,
that's what the law said.
Hot,
hot twist and hair.
Right?
It's fucking ridiculous.
Do you know in some states,
if you're riding in a car with,
with like a girl who's not of age and she's in her bare feet,
that's considered statutory rape.
Does that make any fucking sense?
It doesn't,
does it?
Well,
I'm gonna tell you right now,
these fucking divorce laws make as much sense is that they like these old
archaic fucking laws.
This is the thing,
you know,
there's a lot of disadvantages to being a lady.
But you know,
one of the main advantages of being a woman is that you can be an absolute
fucking bomb.
You could be a bum.
You can have no fucking job,
no drive.
You cannot achieve anything in life
and still come out the other side worth $400 million.
Okay.
Do you know what happens to a guy?
If he's a bum,
he's a bum.
He's fucking homeless other than Stedman Stedman.
Oprah's fucking whatever the hell he is.
He's the only guy I ever saw that figured out how to be a fucking bum.
Okay.
Oh,
there's a car actually.
Glad.
Let's be fair.
Kevin Federline.
Kevin Federline is a bump.
That guy is a bum.
Brittany Spears even built him his own God damn recording studio and he still
couldn't make a hit.
Right?
Then they get divorced and what does he do?
Sits on his ass and becomes a fat fuck.
You know,
getting Popeye's fried chicken off of Brittany Spears,
alimony payments.
He's a bump.
So I guess it can be done.
But come on.
Who's getting hope?
It's very few and far between.
You know,
I dunno,
maybe women are coming up.
Maybe they are making more money.
I saw all those Christmas ads,
those Lexus ads where these women were buying their guys cars and I got to admit
I was sitting there.
I started acting like a woman.
When I saw that commercial,
I was like,
yeah,
why don't you buy me a car?
Like this fictitious couple that we see on television.
That really bothered me.
Seeing that commercial where these women were out there buying cars,
not because my male ego couldn't handle some broad buying me a car.
It's just the fact that they're putting this out.
There wasn't multiple commercials as if this shit is going on is if there's so
many fucking women out there by in their fucking men's a car that it's worthy of
putting it out there like this is some mainstream shit that happens.
Hey fellas,
how many guys Honi I'm in.
Your male friends got a fucking goddamn Volkswagen.
Forget about Lexus for Christmas.
Anybody you see any of your male friends walking outside screaming like a bitch
in that bathrobe jumping up and down and look at some shiny new car with a big
ribbon on it?
Has that ever happened?
I read Oprah.
Did it.
I Bet Brittany did it.
Who else?
Yeah,
Sandra Bullock.
She married a bum.
Okay.
That's another guy.
You know those guys out to write a book because they're really treading on some
female shit.
Like how to live like a Hooters chick as a guy.
You know how to just be an absolute fucking bum and still come out the other
side of God damn millionaire.
Okay.
I gotta be honest with you.
I couldn't fucking do it if I was a fucking bum.
All right,
let me just look.
Let's just,
let's just say I was married to somebody,
some lady,
right?
And she's just running some God damn empire coming home every day.
Dress like fucking Nancy Reagan,
you know,
God damn broach just to let you know how powerful she is and uh,
she's buying me all this shit.
I have to,
why I would have to leave the relationship.
I would have to leave and she'd be like the bill.
You have nothing.
I know.
That's the point I got.
I got nothing.
I'm a fucking loser.
I feel like I'm,
I feel like I'm 14 years old and I'm still living at home with my parents.
I can't,
I don't have a job.
I don't have any goals.
I'm not doing anything.
I'm just fucking sitting here going to the gym.
Okay?
Okay.
I know what everything costs on the prices,
right.
I sh I should know that.
Do you understand that?
Okay.
I,
I'm sick of playing tennis with the maid.
I have to do something with my life.
This is fucking pathetic.
Okay.
I know.
I thought it was what I wanted.
I know I got a fucking blow it on sports bar.
I love the beers on tap.
I got the NFL,
NBA Nhl and MLB packages and I'm still not happy cause I'm a bum.
Mrs. Reagan.
All right,
I'm outta here.
Just give me time to find a job in a one bedroom apartment or fucking studio.
I have to get out of here.
You know,
but these broads,
don't give a fuck.
Coby.
Brian's ex wife is a bomb and she's going to be worth close to $200 million.
Do you understand that?
Do it.
He probably probably even won a game of checkers in her life.
You know,
maybe she was good at shoots and ladders.
Yeah.
What does she do?
And I bet she has some bullshit online business.
That's what those rich broads always do.
So they can act like they have some fucking business but still stay at home and
they are fucking jam jams.
And I'm working,
I have a computer,
you know going to fucking US magazine.com all fucking day.
You Rub bomb.
Yeah.
Mrs. Whatever your name is Brian,
you're a fucking bum.
You're a bomb.
Get a fucking job.
Okay.
The fuck is it going to say on your tombstone?
Suck the right dick.
Okay.
Oh Man,
I got all of that one.
Uh,
all right,
it's now I'm actually sick of talking about it.
Maybe I won't.
Maybe that won't go to state.
Who the fuck knows?
Go to stage.
Did I just say that we're taking this to the stage where having a big
production,
alright.
Dilemmas for the week.
Go to the bathroom like a cat number one and number two in a dresser drawer
sized cat box.
And have a butler empty at every day or go to the bathroom like a dog outside in
the bushes and have a Butler follow you around to pick it up and tell you that
you're a good boy.
Oh,
that's no fights.
No Fiat that second one.
I do it outside at squat right down to the fucking bushes,
not shitting inside my house.
That's why I hate cats.
Aside from the fact that they act like stuck up,
cuts at a club,
you know,
who've never done accomplished anything other than looking good in life,
and they only come around when they fucking need something.
The only other reason why I don't like cats and say shit in the fucking house,
then I get to pick it up.
I don't like that.
They're not happy when I come home.
There's just no,
there's no give and take.
You know what is,
when you have a cat,
you're basically Robert De Niro's character in casino.
That's what you are,
you know,
and your cat is Sharon Stone.
She's fucking,
she's just there for the amenities.
You fucking cunt.
Go O D and a Goddamn red roof inn.
All right.
So yeah,
I would definitely outside.
Who doesn't like being told there were a good boy?
I get praise was the last time anybody out there got praise after they took a
dump.
Wouldn't that be awesome?
You know,
I don't know.
All right,
let's plow ahead.
Was that unfunny sir?
Did you not like that one?
Was that not up to your comedy standards?
Did you feel the rest of this podcast was funnier than that when I blew my nose
before I went off on Jesus.
Oh,
alright.
Let's just plow ahead here.
Number two.
Uh,
would you rather marry a stripper or have your daughter become one?
I'd rather Mary Wood and ran a merry one.
You know,
if my daughter becomes one,
that's just complete failure as a parrot.
And in fact that's what I think all those videos,
it should be called that you see,
you know when you see on youtube and you got those girls doing those booty
dances,
you know the god damn shorts up their ass.
Like it's always like so and so booty dancing.
What it should be called is so and so complete failure as a pair of well results
of a complete failure as a parent.
Absolutely.
I would rather,
that's not fair to the kid.
I would marry a stripper and uh,
you know,
I would just,
I would just have fun with the stripper.
I would just do whatever I could,
you know,
fucker is,
she had one leg pointed west and one leg pointed east,
you know,
or north and south if she's standing up drinking coffee,
doing like one of those little ballet moves.
I just bang like that and then,
uh,
yeah,
don't have a kid and be like,
listen,
this is the secret in life,
sweetheart.
Don't do anything that your mother did when she does become a stripper.
Is that like a reality show that they haven't come up with yet?
Daughters of strippers?
Like what's her face?
I think a Kurt Cobain's daughter is going to be all right because their mother
is such a fuck up that I think I probably just jinxed her.
I probably just jinxed her.
Um,
all right.
Number three,
uh,
choose between attacked by a bear or a lion on land in between.
Attacked by a shark or a crocodile in the water.
No fucking contest,
dude.
I would take a bear or a lion.
That's a quick death.
That's a quick one.
That bear comes up with that bionic bitch slap.
That's it.
It fucking breaks your neck.
You ever see a lion kill something?
That's it.
It's over like,
and that's going after like major prey and it just crushes you.
Fucking wind pipe.
You're out in two seconds.
Did you ever yell the footage of,
what's his face?
The Gay Lion Tamer out there.
The one who looked like,
uh,
what's his face from night at the Roxbury?
The AH,
Jesus Christ is fucking cold medicine.
What the fuck is the guy's name there?
Come on.
What was,
what's the name of that guy?
Chris Catan.
That one.
The Gay Chris Catan.
Do you ever see when that fucking,
that lion grabbed that dude and it was over in two seconds.
It would,
he just went limp.
I take that in a second as opposed to a fucking shark.
You sitting out there,
a shark comes up,
first thing it does is it bites and the leg to see if your edible right just
takes a nice chunk out in class.
You know,
like it's doing some sort of wine testing with your fucking thigh meat.
You know what else kills me is the fact you can't fucking see it.
You know,
your heads above the water and all the evil is just below it and you're sitting
there,
you know,
and I think that you hit still,
you got that cavemen DNA that would,
that would just be going off that there was something in the area despite the
fact that you couldn't see it,
you'd be trying to lift your fucking legs up.
I,
I think,
uh,
I think the real dilemma here is,
is between shark or a crocodile and,
uh,
I,
I would have to go,
I would have to go shark.
I just feel like they're,
it's a cleaner death.
You know,
they got those Ginsu knives,
teeth,
they just come in like a tiger shark is just fucking over,
you know,
just a perfect fucking killing machine as they said in jaws.
But like a
alligators and crocodiles,
those fucking things.
Those are like those guys who aren't talent talented enough to be in the NFL,
the NHL.
So they just go out there and they try to blow out guys knees,
you know,
alligators and crocodiles and like the bill room now skis of fucking predators.
You know,
just that thing where they grab on to you.
You know what I like about shark?
It you could just bite your leg off.
Ugh.
Fucking alligator.
That they always seem to grab it and then they go into that role and they just
sold slowly twisted off.
You know,
like you some cooked chicken and they're trying to take the leg.
This is getting fucking morbid.
That's what I would choose.
All right,
what else we got here?
Uh,
have a beautiful lady who stinks,
smelly breath,
smelly ass pussy pits,
hair the works,
all stinking or an ugly fat bitch who smells great.
Uh,
I go with the ugly fat girls.
Smells great.
Absolutely because I could,
I could love her.
Where the other one who just smelled like shit but was beautiful.
It was probably carried herself like a beautiful lady would annoy me after a
while and I'd probably kill her,
you know?
Why did you kill her?
Because her fucking pussy stunk and she walked around like she was just sell.
Am I being charged with that?
He think because if I am,
I want a lawyer.
Go fuck yourselves.
While Mr. Burns,
you really just already incriminated yourself.
I don't care.
You know,
the prison will not smell as bad as her ass.
I was anything worse to fucking cold tea.
All right,
here we go.
A chimp first linebacker built my friends and I frequently get in an argument
over whether a worlds,
a world's man competitor or NFL lineman could handle a chimp in a fight.
I know chimps can rip faces off at a 10 times the strength of a normal man,
but a normal man is a tub of shit.
I bet a linebacker could rip some faces off to.
What do you think?
Uh,
yeah,
no contest.
The chimp would fuck the dude up.
Do Chimps don't fight.
I was going to have a said fairly chimps don't fight like people.
They're not going to,
you know,
you've got to come out,
come out and touch gloves and they're going to fuck it.
Sorry.
He's got a great jab watch out for it's right.
You know that fucking thing is just going to jump on you.
I would tell you that time that monkey stole my hotel keys.
I was in Costa Rica.
Um,
the fuck was I down in Costa Rica,
way out in the Bush,
you know,
army ants took over my fucking little Cabana and that type of shit.
So they had this pet monkey.
There of is a monkey.
I fucking hate monkeys.
I never had a problem with chimps,
but now that they'd rip people's faces off and then nuts and their feet off,
I have a problem with them.
Uh,
I like gorillas and I like orangutans.
Orangutans.
I was thought I was tank t a n g but it's wearing a tan.
I like those ones.
They seem like they've seen it all.
They got that vibe.
They could just sit down and teach you about life.
But those little monkey motherfuckers,
I can't stand it.
Right.
So for some dumb reason,
cause I'm white,
I have to walk up to it.
Hey,
there's a fucking wild animal.
Let me put myself in danger.
And I walk up to this thing and a fucking jumps on me.
Uh,
you know,
and it's one of those,
remember that that video was shocked.
The monkey popup with the little monkey in that day was one of those monkeys or
the faces of death when they will fucking banging that monkey's head till it
died than the aide is brains.
Remember that one?
Yeah,
it was one of those monkeys,
right?
This fucking thing jumped on me.
And within half a second,
it turned itself upside down,
was hanging by its tail from my neck,
reached in my pockets,
grabbed my keys and ran back up a fucking tree.
This all happened like within like 1.8 seconds.
So my body like,
what?
Wait,
What?
Ah,
fuck.
So if this thing actually wanted to fuck you up,
the things that going to come out.
Fuck it.
Bobbing and weaving.
It's going to be running around the room,
jumping up off a shit.
You got to try to figure out where it is and it's just going to fucking land on
your face and that's going to be it.
It's going to tear your face off,
twist your foot off and rip your balls off and no linebacker stands a fucking
chance unless you know what,
what if they had on the equipment,
even though they tell you fingers off.
This is the amazing thing about how human beings survived,
is everything out there as far as I can tell,
is faster than us.
For the most part,
it is stronger that US faster and stronger,
but for the simple fact that we were smarter,
we were able to do all the horrific things that we've done with this nature.
You know,
with this nature,
with this planet.
Yeah,
but think about that shit.
Football players beat the fuck out of the nerds all through grade school and
high school.
Then what happens from the real deal goes down the end of the day.
Those nerds become bankers and those football players get enslaved there.
You sit in your house like a caged animal,
like the fucking zoo it.
Where's that banker?
You don't even know what the fuck he looks like.
All those Facebook cunts,
that Goddamn Steve Jobs,
the most overrated human beings are the fucking planet they went in yet.